♪ ♪
>> Chris: AS POLICYMAKERS
DEBATE WHEN AND HOW TO REOPEN
STATE ECONOMIES, PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS CONTINUE TO WARN ABOUT
THE DANGER OF MOVING TOO FAST.
JOINING US NOW FROM BALTIMORE,
DR. TOM INGLESBY, DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH SECURITY
AT JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY.
DOCTOR, GOOD TO BE WITH YOU
AGAIN.
>> Dr. Inglesby: GOOD MORNING,
CHRIS.
>> Chris: WHERE ARE WE WITH
THE VIRUS?
HAVE WE REACHED THE PEAK, ARE WE
ON THE DOWNSLOPE OF THE VIRUS,
AND ALL THAT WE SEE THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS OVER 53,000, ALMOST
54,000 THIS MORNING, CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE OF THE RANGE, OF
HOW MANY DEATHS WE MAY SEE FROM
THIS VIRUS OVERALL DEPENDING ON
HOW CAREFUL WE ARE IN THE
REOPENING?
>> Dr. Inglesby: YES.
I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE, FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD, MAY BE
NEAR END OF THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PANDEMIC IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE REACHED A PLATEAU
NATIONALLY AT THIS POINT.
TRENDS CAN CHANGE OVER TIME BUT
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE A PLATEAU
IN NEW CASES PER DAY.
UNFORTUNATELY IT’S A VERY HIGH
PLATEAU.
WE STILL ARE SEEING ABOUT 30,000
NEW CASES OF COVID-19 EVERY DAY
IN THE UNITED STATES AND STILL
ARE SEEING SOMETHING ON THE
ORDER OF 2,000 DEATHS PER DAY,
SO WE ARE NOT THROUGH -- OUT OF
THE WORDS BY ANY MEANS IN TERMS
OF THIS PANDEMIC BUT AT LEAST WE
REACHED KIND OF A STABLE NUMBER
OF NEW INFECTIONS IN THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING FROM
THIS ILLNESS.
ONE MUST POINT --
>> Chris: LET ME JUST SAY WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT MODELS,
1 MILLION PEOPLE, THEN IT WAS
100,000 PEOPLE, THEN IT WAS 60.
NOW WE ARE ALREADY UP TO 53,000,
SO GIVE ME A SENSE OF THE
NUMBER -- I UNDERSTAND HIS OR
PREDICTIONS, BUT THE NUMBER OF
FATALITIES WE MIGHT SEE FROM
THIS.
>> Dr. Inglesby: SO I THINK
MODELERS ARE PRETTY RELUCTANT TO
MODEL WAY BEYOND A MONTH OR TWO
OUT FROM NOW BECAUSE OF SO MANY
VARIABLES.
IF WE CHANGE OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING POLICIES AND
DEPENDING ON HOW WELL STATES GET
PREPARED FOR THE EASING INTO THE
REOPENING, THAT COULD CHANGE
OUTCOMES QUITE A BIT.
BUT THE LEADING MODELS AT THE
MOMENT PROTECT ANYWHERE FROM
58,000 DEATHS TO 110,000 DEATHS
IN THE NEXT MONTH IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I THINK NO ONE IS REALLY
MODELING BEYOND THAT AND REALLY
IT’S GOING TO DEPEND ON MANY
THINGS THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO
WRAP UP INTO A SINGLE NUMBER.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, LET ME
ASK YOU ONE MORE QUESTION,
TRYING TO FORESEE THE FUTURE.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE GAVE A
TIMELINE THIS WEEK FOR ONE WE
ARE GOING TO COME OUT OF THIS.
HERE HE IS.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE TRENDS
TODAY THAT I THINK BY
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND WE WILL
LARGELY HAVE THIS CORONAVIRUS
EPIDEMIC BEHIND US.
>> Chris: MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND, DOCTOR, IS THAT
REALISTIC?
>> Dr. Inglesby: AT THIS POINT
IF YOU GO STATE-BY-STATE, YOU
SEE THAT ABOUT HALF OF THE
COUNTRY AND HALF OF THE COUNTRY,
THE NUMBERS ARE STILL RISING
DAY-TO-DAY.
ABOUT ANOTHER THIRD OF THE
COUNTRY THERE SEEMS TO BE
LEVELING OFF AND ONLY A
MINORITY -- A MINORITY OF THE
COUNTRY THAT NUMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY COMING DOWN DAY BY DAY.
SO I DON’T THINK IT’S LIKELY
THAT WE WILL BE AT THAT POSITION
BY MEMORIAL DAY BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WHEREVER WE ARE IN
THE EPIDEMIC, THIS VIRUS IS
GOING TO BE WITH US UNTIL WE
HAVE A VACCINE, SO AS WE EASE UP
ON SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES
AND ECONOMIES BEGIN TO VERY
CAREFULLY REOPEN, WE ARE AT RISK
OF RECURRENCE OR RE-SPIKES IN
THE ILLNESS IN THE EPIDEMIC.
I THINK EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE
AWARE THAT EVEN AS WE ARE
BEGINNING TO OPEN UP AGAIN,
THERE IS A CLEAR CHANCE OF A
RISE IN CASES IN STATES THAT ARE
DOING THAT.
>> Chris: LET’S TALK ABOUT
THAT, BECAUSE A NUMBER OF
STATES, AS YOU KNOW, ARE
BEGINNING TO REOPEN.
SPAS, SALONS, GYMS, EVEN
RESTAURANTS.
IS THAT SAFE -- YOU KNOW, YOU
TALK ABOUT A SPOT WHERE PEOPLE
ARE GIVING MASSAGES, A SALON
WHERE PEOPLE ARE FILING PEOPLES
NAILS ARE CUTTING THEIR HAIR, IS
THAT SAFE FOR PEOPLE TO BE THAT
CLOSE AT THIS POINT IF THEY’RE
WEARING MASKS AND GLOVES?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I DON’T THINK
IT’S GOING TO BE POSSIBLE FOR
ANYONE TO SAY THAT IT’S
COMPLETELY SAFE, COMPLETELY SAFE
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE THE VIRUS
IS VERY TRANSMISSIBLE BETWEEN
PEOPLE AND BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE
DON’T HAVE SYMPTOMS, AT LEAST
EITHER IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
ILLNESS OR MAYBE EVEN AT ALL
DURING THEIR ILLNESS.
BUT WE CAN SAVE SOME THINGS ARE
SAFER THAN OTHERS AND BUSINESSES
THAT HAD SMALL NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
ARE PROBABLY SAFER THAN
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE VERY LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE AND THE
CLOSENESS OF THE INTERACTION
THAT ALSO IS A FACTOR, SO PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE CLOSELY
INTERACTING, THEY SHOULD BE
USING PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT IF THAT’S AVAILABLE IN
THEIR STATES.
AND OUTDOORS WILL BE SAFER THAN
INDOORS -- SO THERE IS A RANGE
OF DIFFERENT -- THERE’S GOING TO
BE A RANGE OF DIFFERENT RISKS
THAT BUSINESSES FACE AND IT’S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL BUSINESSES NOW
TO TRY AND UNDERSTAND THE RISKS
AND MAKING PLANS FOR HOW TO
DIMINISH THE RISKS AS BEST THEY
CAN WITHIN THEIR OWN BUSINESS,
THEIR OWN OPERATIONS.
>> Chris: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUICK DIRECT QUESTION, WOULD YOU
FEEL SAFE AT THIS POINT GETTING
A HAIRCUT, GETTING A MASSAGE IF
YOU AND THE PERSON DOING IT WERE
BOTH WEARING GLOVES AND MASKS?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I THINK AT
THIS POINT IN MOST PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY WITH THE RATE OF ILLNESS
AS IT IS, I DON’T THINK SO.
THERE MAY BE SOME PLACES WHERE
COMMUNITY -- COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION IS SO LOW AND
TESTING IS SO GOOD THAT WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE RISK IS LOW,
BUT I’D SAY I WOULD BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT DOING THAT AT THIS POINT.
>> Chris: YOU TALK ABOUT
TESTING.
I KNOW ONE OF THE PROBLEMS YOU
HAVE WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
GUIDELINES IS THAT YOU THINK
THEY FAILED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING.
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THAT
THIS WEEK.
>> WE ARE DOING VERY WELL IN
TESTING, WE TESTED FAR MORE THAN
ANYBODY ELSE ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
>> THAT WE ARE JUST NOT THERE
YOU?
>> I WOULD NOT AGREE WITH THEM
ON THAT, I THINK WE’RE DOING A
GREAT JOB IN TESTING.
>> Chris: WE ARE AVERAGING --
AVERAGING ABOUT 150,000 TESTS A
DAY, ISN’T THAT ENOUGH?
>> Dr. Inglesby: NO, IT’S NOT
ENOUGH AND THE REASON WHY IS
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT TESTING A LOT
OF THE MILD AND MODERATE ILLNESS
THAT PEOPLE WHO AREN’T SICK
ENOUGH TO BE IN THE HOSPITAL AND
SO ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GETTING COUNTED AND THEY ARE
NECESSARILY HAVING THEIR
CONTACTS TRACED OR TOLD TO
ISOLATE IN THEIR OWN HOMES, SO
WE ARE MISSING A LOT OF THE
ILLNESS IN THE COUNTRY.
UNTIL WE GET THAT UNDER CONTROL
WHERE GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
MINDS OF TRANSMISSION THAT WE
CAN SEE, AND BEYOND THAT, MANY
BUSINESSES AND ARE REALLY
BEGINNING TO THINK ABOUT HOW
DIAGNOSTICS MIGHT FACTOR INTO
THE REOPENING PLANS AND WE JUST
DON’T HAVE DIAGNOSTIC TESTING
AVAILABLE ON LARGE-SCALE FOR
BUSINESSES.
WE ARE STILL FOCUSED ON
DIAGNOSING THE SICKEST PEOPLE,
THOSE IN NURSING HOMES,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, WHICH IS
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE, BUT
THERE ARE A SMALL FRACTION OF A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WE ARE GOING TO
NEED TO TEST TO REALLY FIND ALL
THE ILLNESS AND TO GET THE
ECONOMY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AGAIN.
>> Chris: I WANT TO SQUEEZE
TWO MORE QUESTIONS IN HERE AND
THE TIME WE HAVE LEFT HERE,
DOCTOR.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT ANOTHER
WHITE HOUSE GUIDELINE, AND THAT
IS A STEADY DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF NEW CASES OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO WEEKS.
I WANT TO PUT SOME STATS ON THE
SCREEN.
IF OKLAHOMA IS DOWN FROM ITS
PEAK, BUT HAD A 26% INCREASE IN
NEW CASES IN THE LAST WEEK.
AND IT WENT, OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST WEEK, FROM THE
NUMBER -- THE NUMBERS JUMPED
FROM A LOW OF 29 NEW CASES LAST
SUNDAY TO OVER 100 NEW CASES
JUST THIS PAST THURSDAY AND
FRIDAY.
SHOULD A STATE WITH THOSE KINDS
OF NUMBERS BE REOPENING NOW?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I WOULD BE
VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT DOING THAT.
I THINK WE’VE SEEN -- THERE’S AN
EXAMPLE IN THE PAPERS THIS
MORNING ABOUT A STATE IN JAPAN
THAT REOPEN QUICKLY IN MARCH
AFTER A FEW WEEKS OF LOW-ISH
NUMBERS IN THREE WEEKS LATER
REBOUNDED TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY HAVE TO CLOSE THEIR ECONOMY
DOWN AGAIN, SO I THINK IT’S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT TO REALLY
GO SLOWLY THOUGH STATES THAT DO
REOPEN, I THINK IT SHOULD BE
DONE VERY CAREFULLY WITH A LOT
OF MONITORING OF BOTH
HOSPITALIZATION RATE, I SEE YOU
RATES, DEATH RATES.
AT THIS RATE ONLY ABOUT FIVE
STATES IN THE COUNTRY, TO MY
ACCOUNT HAVE HAD TWO WEEKS OF
DECLINE, SO ONLY ABOUT TWO
STATES -- FIVE STATES, RATHER,
IN THE COUNTRY HAVE MET THE
GATING CRITERIA LAID OUT BY THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Chris: I’VE GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE LEFT FOR ONE FINAL
QUESTION.
AS YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
COME UNDER FIRE OVER THE LAST
WEEK OR SO, FIRST FOR ADVOCATING
THE USE OF HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
AND THEN LATER THIS WEEK, THIS
WEEK, FOR TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY, SPECULATING ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF INJECTING
DISINFECTANT.
HERE HE IS ON THAT.
>> I SEE THE DISINFECTANT KNOCKS
IT OUT IN A MINUTE, ONE MINUTE
AND IS THERE A WAY WE CAN DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BY INJECTION
INSIDE OR ALMOST A CLEANING.
>> Chris: I KNOW YOU WANT TO
STAY AWAY FROM POLITICS AND I
THINK IT’S CLEAR THAT ANY KIND
OF INGESTION OF A DISINFECTANT
IS DANGEROUS, BUT TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS.
ONE, WHERE ARE YOU AT THIS POINT
ABOUT THE USE OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND TWO, HOW
DO WE SORT THROUGH ALL OF THE
CONFLICTING ADVICE THAT WE GET?
>> Dr. Inglesby: WELCOME TO
YOUR FIRST QUESTION, I THINK THE
DASH THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
STUDY OF HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
TWO STUDIES THAT HAVE COME OUT
SO FAR HAVE SUGGESTED THAT IT IS
POSSIBLY MORE HARMFUL THAN
HELPFUL AND POSSIBLY DANGEROUS,
SO I DON’T THINK ANYBODY SHOULD
BE TAKING HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
UNLESS THEY ARE IN A RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED TRIAL THAT’S BEEN
CAREFULLY STUDIED.
IN THE SECOND POINT IS THAT I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
NOW IN TERMS OF MEDICINES AND
VACCINES IS TO FOLLOW WHERE
MEDICAL LEADERS AND SCIENTIFIC
LEADERS GUIDE US.
THEY ARE DOING THE STUDIES,
THESE STUDIES TAKE TIME.
THESE MEDICINES COULD ACTUALLY
HURT PEOPLE, SO THERE IS HARM
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY HAPPEN IF
PEOPLE TAKE MEDICINES THAT
AREN’T STUDIED SO IT’S IMPORTANT
TO FOLLOW SCIENTISTS.
>> Chris: DR. INGLESBY,
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US AGAIN AND